about two three years into my
recruitment career I lost my dad to
cancer never had any real sort of
hardship or grief up until then in my in
my life
um but because I've gone through that
sort of hardship I now think like I've
got such a resilience to really anything
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of the
recruitment mentors podcast I'm your
host Tisha mizzouz and on this week's
episode I was joined by Matt hacker
you've been in the recruitment industry
for just over a decade 2018 220 Grand
2019 100 Grand last year he broke the
million all our focusing is on high
value business and generating the most
Revenue over the last two years he is
best known as the back-to-back top
performer in the company what do you
believe are the common characteristics
and traits top performing Recruiters in
today's market have I would say
what he's become world class at which we
dig into is account management internal
recruitment relationships and MSP
relationships I think it's massively
underrated the relationship you have
with the MSP the MSP will actually give
you the key to the house we discuss it
all in this episode how he manages a day
how he opens up doors how he builds
relationships and so much more enjoy
this week's episode
Matt welcome to the podcast hello how
you doing I'm good kovid obviously
gotten away the first time yeah we're
back in on a very sunny days it's a lot
more sweater in here than it's ever been
yeah no aircon at all so uh we got we're
gonna have a good old chat in the heat
is sweaty but there's a lot to cover
which I know you know a lot of people
that listen to this podcast are going to
be excited to learn and take from your
journey so I guess before I ask you the
the million pound question which we
would like to start with just to give
everyone some immediate context and if
you feel like I've missed anything
Critical with this then then let me know
and help me out but obviously you've
been in the recruitment industry for
just over a decade this is a quite nice
moment to reflect and think about the
last decade because I think you went
into recruitment April 2013. yeah right
it's been a long time it's gone very
quick yeah and so you've been at Aston
Carter the entire time yeah yeah
obviously you've ended up you know doing
different markets these things which
we're going to get into that but have
you you've always have you always been
dual desk or have I got that wrong so no
yeah you've got that right I'll start
off contract purely contracts okay move
to dual desk and I'll set up a new desk
which would have been 2017 2017. okay so
2013 2017 contract from 2017 up to now
yeah it's more dual desk yeah so in
terms of what that's look like I've got
down here because we were you know
trying to map out this performance
Journey that you've been on but
ultimately what I've got down here is
2018 performance 220 Grand 2019 400
Grand 2020 went back down to around 200
2021 got back up to 580 and then last
year you broke the million um pound
Billings Mark now what that looks like
when we can go into more details um in
this as we have the conversation but
high level staff again feel free to
correct me here uh how that's broken
down obviously not to the exact pound
but we've got about 850 that was
contract
and the rest was around uh perm so that
was around 150 Mark yeah actually double
check the figures before I come down
it's about 220 per um okay across this
contract yeah perfect so
um and then and then in terms of like
just just quickly because then this will
help people I think you've got his are
you in there's 13 people in your
function including you right and I think
you shared with me you've got free
people that do sales and they're
entirely focus on their business yep
that's include a four including me four
including you and then you've got the
rest are in delivery rolls yeah so one
sort of tenant lead that's managing the
talent Associates who are doing
resourcing yeah Okay cool so we'll go
into that but that's like makeup of
where we are today that Journey
obviously there's loads to uh uncover
here so actually why don't we just add
and then let's just add markets because
this is what I think is quite cool about
your story is obviously historically
started in like the banking space right
yeah so I was doing accounting Finance
within financial services and since 2017
jack of all trades master of none so
what does that mean just just quickly
for people so like to give us an example
of different sectors that you've worked
with over the last 12 months and you
know some of the you know three to four
typical roles that you might find
yourself working yeah so it's basically
three three main pillars so it's sales
and marketing HR and procurement and
customer service and admin and we um
yeah deliver perm contract to pretty
much any any sector including bank now
but 95 I'd say of our current bases
um outside of banking so commercially
industry so it could be media Telco
Pharma uh technology yeah real variety
yeah exactly okay so I know that would
be really helpful for people because
people will be thinking that immediately
so let's start with the million pound
question because I'm sure you thought
about this because it's something that
you shared me you're passionate about is
helping people to become successful in
recruitment right so
um
what do you believe are the common
characteristics and traits that top
performing Recruiters in today's market
have what what are the the common things
that you often find in people I would
say
a very high growth mindset so being
adaptable to change and being able to
step outside your comfort zone so it's a
triosity Wrigley in the top performers
I'd say that's one
secondly
a been able to compartmentalize so what
I mean by that is balancing out the lows
from the highest so not getting too
excited once you've done a deal not
getting too down if you've had a drop
out for example when I think that helps
in crisis time so you rarely see like a
really top performer
um you know panicking in a crisis
usually they can take a step aside look
at the facts and then make an informed
decision from there
um and also a
high value mentality as well so being
able to Target the higher business
opportunities the high value business
opportunities that are going to generate
the most revenue for you and being
disciplined and been able to say no to
Bad Business obviously those three
things you're a football fan yep I was
just thinking then the second one you
were just describing Arsenal fans
[Music]
in terms of so high it's so low but yeah
I can say about Chelsea's I'm a Chelsea
fan like I said about last year as well
um so look obviously a lot that we want
to cover today I think when we prepare
for this when we you know we spoke about
this podcast I think you you said you
said to me that something that I
definitely do want to try and talk about
um is you know an important part of your
journey in your story that
hopefully you know by you sharing by you
talking about your own experiences it
can help other people and I really
commend that so obviously the the year
where a lot changed for you was
um Chrome if I'm wrong here 2017. it was
yeah it's probably about a year or a
year before that or so yeah so I might
be sorry 2015 about two years into your
career sorry about two freezing
um so why didn't you talk talk to in
your own words why that was a pivotal
year for you and then you know if
there's some questions that come up that
I think maybe it could be helpful for
people to
um you know maybe listen your response
to and then we can go from there and
talk about all the recruitment stuff but
yeah I really recommended the fact that
that was something that you wanted to
really make sure that we spoke about so
let's start there if that's okay with
you yeah of course yeah it's quite
difficult for me to speak about this
I'll be honest with you because I'm not
really like an open book but yeah well
I'll try and help with that so that's
why you start wherever you want and then
we can take it yeah yeah that's cool so
yeah about two three years into my
recruitment career with Aston Carter um
I lost my dad
um to cancer
and a few months after that I also lost
my nan and Granddad so it's all happened
within a fairly short space of time
um never had any real sort of hardship
or grief up until then in my in my life
um
Aston Carter really really good with me
offered me a lot of supporters off work
for I think it was three months I was
off for
um following that I was seeing a
counselor for 18 months two years I was
on antidepressants so it's pretty much
fair to sales Rock Bottom
um how old are you so two three years
old have been late 20s 28 29.
um yeah and even when I got got back to
work I was taking a lot of sick days
like when I look back now I was thinking
I was off work a lot I was didn't even
want to leave the house let alone go to
work
um got through that tough tough period
And I suppose it all changed really when
I was asked to set up this new desk
which was in January I think 2017 yeah
yeah it's a little bit now I can't
remember what years we yeah that's right
yeah we write those things down so no I
appreciate you sharing that I guess that
I said you didn't either you know two
I'm I'm 30 years old two of my best
mates lost their mum to cancer it is
just such a like when you hear someone
is like they're really ill or
something's bad happened that is
probably one of the top three things
that you probably think that that work
answer right so I guess is there
anything that you've found because I'm
sure you've ended up in different ways
connecting with people that might have
been through similar things I'm assuming
that but have you you know why didn't I
ask you that has there been anything
that you found be helpful for people
that
have gone through similar things has
there been anything that yeah you've
shared with people or people shared with
you that you found helpful for anyone
listening that you know might be in that
right now or might still be in that real
I don't feel I'm touched word I haven't
actually had I haven't lost anything I
haven't gone through that proper Griefer
as my partner has and she always says to
me that she feels like grief never
really goes away there'll be moments
where just random moments where you
think about your nan passing or these
things that you have those moments so
like I don't know if there's anything
you know that you found to be helpful
yeah I mean I mean I was fortunate in
the sense that I'd uh well uh girlfriend
is a very strong person she's my wife
now at the time they're good close
friends friends around me close family
around me to I'm not sort of person that
opens up and talks very much about this
sort of stuff but I suppose to
counseling and and that's what I'd like
to be going out and speaking to people
about it definitely did help
um why did that help you then do you
think just because like as I said I'm
not a person that speaks openly about
anything and I'm not very emotional I
don't think I've I don't think I can't
remember the last time I Cry when I was
a teenager I can't remember but um so
I've been able to like actually speak
about like having an outlet to speak
about that so I suppose yeah if you're
going through hardship or grief or
something I'll just I'll just recommend
speaking to people about it even though
how difficult that could be just finding
speaking to someone for me it was easy
to speak to someone completely outside
like a counselor who didn't know me at
all then my close my close like friends
and family why do you think that is them
because you might feel like they're I
don't know you're protecting them
judging you or making assumptions about
you yeah not necessarily judging but
maybe you've shown vulnerability which
is something as a manager now I'm I
think is actually a good trait to show
in a management role but at that time I
was looking to be strong for maybe
everyone else yeah rather than thinking
about thinking about myself like did you
have siblings yeah I got a younger
sister so sort of being strong for her
exactly I don't want to show any
vulnerability at all that was my
um it's not like a decision it's just my
natural yeah it's just like um yeah
so I guess I I have to ask him because
you said it already and you even said
that we're preparing for this like
you've already said like you're not
someone typically that shows emotions or
opens up but then you're saying what was
really helpful was opening up yeah yeah
so I guess what I wanted to like
there'll be a lot of people that relate
to that so I guess is there anything
that maybe you can share that because I
sat down with a guy called
um Dan who lost his uh dad to suicide
and like it took him ages to pick up the
phone and say to his mum I need help
yeah but that wasn't like therapy
session one so was that was there any
was there anything you know looking back
that I don't know made you feel more
comfortable sharing or just maybe
sharing a thing that for people that
that seems so out of the question to
even open up and be vulnerable at all
that maybe you can help them go you know
what if you do arrive at that position
it is helpful and maybe worth trying to
get there but was there anything that
helps you get to a point where you was
willing to open up because I'm sure it
just didn't happen overnight because
you've described yourself it's sort of
like understanding that if you don't do
that it's just gonna bottle up and it's
just gonna get worse and worse and worse
and worse so you it's almost like I
force myself to do it so as I said like
I didn't start that for a good few
months after until I was at work so it
must be not at least three four months
after everything happened before I'd
done that
um yeah the alternative is for it to
bottle up which reduces worse
do you feel do you feel like that was
starting to happen in those first three
to four months then was that what sort
of maybe triggered that maybe I should
speak to someone and I think all of
everyone coats stuff differently right
yeah I mean it was just to try and
ignore everything that's happening and
trying to crack on in a way yeah that's
not always the best thing
yeah I mean I can't even comprehend that
and especially obviously that that age
as well because it's Das
like what I always think about with my
um
friends is like
your your parents like if you lose them
at that age like they miss out so much
like it's sad man it's tough like my
um my friend who has been the first on
our friendship group to
um have a have a child and like
unfortunately he's not gonna be able to
show his mom and they're the things that
you think just happen yeah we all get to
experience that right
that's why I really commend you talking
about it because it's it's it's
hard
um
so I wasn't sorry I was gonna say one of
the things that has come out of that as
well like linking it back to sort of
recruitment is because I've gone through
that sort of hardship I now think like
I've got such a resilience to really
anything especially like recruitment
based cross stuff yeah if stuff if
something happens now like I get a drop
out or a client says this quite yeah it
doesn't like it Pals insignificant to
what yeah
and I've heard people say that because
it is so much so much of resilience I
feel like what what helps me you know
have better chances of overcoming
challenges is perspective and I can
quite easily I haven't gone through the
hardships that you've gone through but
I've really tried to you know be good at
going well at least I'm not homeless or
this could be happening or that could be
happening so I'm not surprised that you
know you going through that experience
one of the positive things that will
come out of it is you know then moving
forward in your life things that maybe
could really hold people back or people
really struggle with you're like well
this isn't that this is nowhere near as
part of what I've been through yeah
exactly and sometimes a lot of people
don't have that perspective
classic interview questions is like can
you tell me about a time when you had to
bounce back from yeah some sort of
hardship or you know recovered from a
situation but obviously like what
happened to me is probably more extreme
of that but yeah similar sort of thing
yeah
so you've then obviously gone on to
really apply yourself in in work
so why don't we why don't I just start
then because we're talking about this
one like a lot of people because as I
shared with you like I did a post saying
that I was gonna sit down with someone
that broke the million pound Mark
obviously so many people think that's
not possible in their market so you know
really interested by that so why don't I
just start with this particularly with
us all understanding that you've worked
in industry for a decade
let me just start with like what do you
think from that moment you've done to
ultimately
you know build a sustainable career and
not burn yourself out and not you know
get into the the performance that you've
got to let's be honest unless you tell
us otherwise probably involves some sort
of sacrifice
yeah I've read those questions by the
way and I thought they were quite funny
yes
so why don't we why don't we just start
with that like what do you think Matt
has been able to do or what have you had
to get better at when it comes to you
know not putting everything I know you
said you know your um girlfriend who's
now your wife
but like over the this period you could
have just thrown everything at work and
it's all work work work and then your
friendship maybe suffers your
relationship suffers so what do you
think you've
um done to help maintain the you know
over a long period of time you're still
here you're showing up you're doing it
and over the long period of time you've
actually just got better and better yeah
this might sound mad but I work Less
hours now than I did when I first
started so I bought what I've been able
to
I suppose Master is like the what I'm
doing during the day like working
effectively and working smart as opposed
to working long hours like I get into
work probably just a little bit after
eight and I'm Gone by six most days I
know something
urgent you know requires me to stay but
yeah that might sound quite surprising
but I might turn the laptop on in a
couple of hours during the week it's
tidy up on emails or something like that
but generally I reckon I was working a
lot longer out so I know for a fact and
it was in the office as well pre-covered
than I do now
really yeah 100 a lot yeah
how many years do you think that's been
the schedule most of the time the last
two years the last three years better
I've got the less I the less hours I've
worked really I don't know if I'm trying
to create their own behaviors but people
just started out but um but I think what
I suppose what I'm trying to say is like
there's you have a look at what you're
doing I suppose it links into one of the
things I just said earlier about
characteristics is like I all I focus on
is on on high value business and
generating the most Revenue I will not
waste time in what I consider a bad
business and I'm not just when I refer
to bad business I'm not just talking
about
um uh commercials like you know Revenue
exactly I'm talking about you know
what's my competition how many other
agencies work in this role how good is
my relationship with the hiring manager
how well how well do I know this client
what's the candidate Network there's a
lot of variables that go into what I'd
consider good business and bad business
but yeah I'm very particular now and I
think that's um as I said earlier I
think that's a trait of a lot of high
performers I speak to they can turn
around and say no whereas you know when
I when I first set up a new desktop the
corporate functions team
um back in 2018 I was going after
everything everything I can find like
from my hands on I was going after and
it's mostly playing business it was
mostly what I'd call
um transactional business like spot
placements it wasn't like going to be
anything repeat business from that
um it was mostly perm as well and um
although I'm a dual desk or I hate um
really so it's mostly plan to start with
um so I've learned I've learned a lot
yeah since then so why don't we then
okay because a lot of people
as you can imagine wanted to know Matt
how how does it how does this person set
up their day you've given the bit of a
flavor of that book with what you've
just shared you would have been
describing
a lot of people maybe right now with
where they are in their career in terms
of like you just said maybe working on
transactional business a lot of sport
business
and you've then obviously gone on a
journey to what you've just said look I
basically make sure where my time has
been spent is in the most valuable
places and we'll get into you know what
you always look for to give you
confidence that that's you know like
high value business and you're just
giving us a bit of an example
if we can try and cast back to you know
those that early on where you was yeah
more in that transactional side sport
business
what do you think was the first you know
one or two things you started to do that
started you know making you take a
trajectory to where you are more now
which is working mainly on high value
business not working as many long hours
like what was the one or two things that
you started to change was it you started
to say no more was it that if you found
out that this Joel uh job specifically
had been already been with five
Arrangements who's not touching it like
what was the one or two things that you
really started to change that then
probably was the first Domino to
it's difficult in that first year
because it was it was terrible I think I
was on my own but I think I've done 145k
but that was like um that wasn't there
was no there's no clients there was
nothing so I done that off the off the
bat purely purely new business but
looking back there I made so many
mistakes that I then learned like future
so if I if I if I knew what I do now I
would have done it totally different
would have like concentrated my business
development
um strategy or more what I'd call
Strategic BD going after more
um volume clients so clients that you're
going to win and you're going to get
repeat business they're going to give
you roles like on a you know secure PSL
for example and I aim to get one of two
of those and that's what we adopt in my
team now we're aiming to get each sales
person is aiming to get you know one to
two of those per year so why is that um
because if you if I've got well
currently I've got say included me if
you've got eight people sales people in
sorry four sales people my team we're
bringing on eight psls per year that's
that's gonna enable us to grow going
forward whereas when I started I was
doing more transactional VD I was
chasing chasing deals off the back of
leads maybe a couple of spec CVS maybe
um speaking to managers that are back of
me referencing candidates and picking up
the odd role here and there so I ended
up doing 145k but it wouldn't surprise
me if they were like I wouldn't do one
deal I've probably done one deal one
deal yeah so if I if I was to go back
then I'd a much better BD strategy in
place okay um proper prospecting
targeting the right clients putting a
plan in place and focusing more on
strategic PD if I if I pick up a few
transactional stuff on the way that's
fine but my sole Focus would have been
more the Strategic side all right I've
definitely got questions for you on that
yeah but like would you say that is the
main thing or is there maybe one other
thing that comes to mind when it comes
to you know getting into a position
where you're not just doing spot
business not just transactional is there
anything so you've said more strategic
BD yep get that and ask you questions on
that was there anything else that you
think you would have done should have
done earlier or from what you've learned
you yeah have now lent into which means
you you've got more repeat business and
whatever
um
so at the at the time all of the all the
deals we were doing were new business
whereas I worked for a large large
company looking back what I should have
been doing is maybe looking at maybe
Legacy existing clients we may be signed
terms of at some point in the last 10
years and not necessarily done anything
with okay because again we'll give you
an example one of it's actually our
current biggest client was what I'd call
like a at that time was like a dormant
account it was just sitting there we had
terms agreed but no one was doing
anything with it and I think I
discovered that in the second year and
that's now I mean this is three four
years later but that's now what now our
biggest how did you discover that was
you looking on the database was you was
it just by accident just taking us I
could step back and thinking look we're
a big company what what other is there
any clients we work in with outside of
outside of banking that I can maybe
leverage from a previous relationship
maybe someone's left or whatever
um I just spoke to our legal team and
said can you give me a list of clients
that we've got we've currently got terms
with which are either run out or dormant
or whatever
um got back in touch and said look I
appreciate we this is you know we used
to work with you doing this on the new
point on the contact going forward I
really want to you know get back in
touch and connect with you again it just
went from there it's funny you say that
because I've experienced this recently
we had a guy called uh Ollie Perry on
the podcast and he said something he's
always trying to remind his team is to
not forget to look backwards
and I really like that like it's what
you're talking about because whoever was
involved in getting to the point of
signing terms did all that hard work and
then like that that still does if you
did all that hard work and you got to
that point of them signing terms that is
something that you can use immediately
whereas if you're just focusing on net
new clients all the time you're doing
all that upfront work to try and get to
that point where they trust you enough
to sign terms there's already an element
of trust there because you're saying hey
look we've done this with you before I'm
now you know doing this do you think
it'd be worth having a conversation and
there's already an element of trust
there because whoever's been involved in
in that you know has worked hard to that
and I think that's something everyone
needs to remember is don't forget to
look backwards and I just did this
exercise not too long ago and ended up
signing two different companies from it
and it is just good to look backwards
and and follow up because you wouldn't
have got to that point without you know
doing the good work to get to that point
and then that you sort of almost can
shortcut things yeah well there's
there's several barriers to entry right
when you when you break a new client and
then just the less the less barriers
there are yeah the easier it is to break
and that's that's one of them if you've
already got term sign and that's one
barrier gone right yeah so let's talk
about the Strategic BD thing because
that was obviously a lot of a lot of
questions came through from people on
how does this person approach BD now how
many different clients are working with
whatever and I'll be honest what you've
just said I think some people will be
surprised I don't know if you agree with
that about the PSL getting some big
house you know big accounts volume
because most common you know I'll be
honest most recruiters I speak to when
they hear the word PSL they're like
that I want to speak to the hiring
manager whatever right and what you're
actually saying and we can go into it
actually what you wish you would have
done sooner is actually have you know
more bigger accounts that you work
really hard to get onto the PSL with and
then do everything that you can to
maximize those relationships and I'm
going to be more confident that you're
gonna get you know way more repeat
business do way more deals which should
mean by the end of the year you've
increased your performance whatever yeah
so let's break down this route BD for a
piece so like I guess like firstly you
said this is something that you're
actually trying to Target your team on
what would you say because you would
have had to learn this the hard way
where do people go wrong when it comes
to signing big accounts like where where
is typically the first most common
stumbling block that you've seen that
you've then helped people with do you
think where do people normally go wrong
when it comes to trying to get in front
of these big accounts and get on psls
whether people normally go wrong um
um they can go wrong at any stage I'll
say to start with you need to make sure
you're prospecting strategy is on point
and you're targeting the right the right
customers I'll say that was a start
point so make sure that's backed up by
data analysis do your market research
the actual prospecting piece is part of
the BD takes a lot longer than the
actual execution in my in my opinion in
terms of actual calling the managers or
emailing the the longest part it
probably takes an hour and a half maybe
a day to do the actual prospecting make
sure you're targeting the right people
customers
um so let's break that down then what do
you mean by that so are we going right
so these are the companies that I want
to focus on because of this these are
the types of people that we need to be
reaching out to like what are some of
the fundamental things that you do in
that stage then so we would I would
always say in terms of Target it look
for look for companies that are growing
maybe you've got maybe for um I've got
high attrition
um have have like more than more a lot
more than one that you're targeting I
would say to my team look Target one if
it's a big big client I'd say Target one
a day a lot of people make the mistake
where they maybe have a few meetings or
and then just give up and move on many
people make the mistake they don't have
enough meetings in that client and move
on with these big ones they took a long
time to to break so I'd suggest like
having a meetings Target in place making
sure you go in you have to map the map
the whole company out find out who the
key stake or the stakeholders are get
the key decision makers who's the MSP on
site and then you're constantly linking
in
um you know do we already know anyone
with this company I'm not building up
maybe a network of candidates that have
left there getting some information and
intelligence as well okay so that like
basically the first thing if you're not
being smart with like taking time to
think about the makeup of these big
companies how you can get in with them
yeah you're going to struggle because it
is I guess it's just like where do we
even start right so that that's
absolutely fundamental so have you found
them what is the typical makeup of
like what what is the typical makeup of
like the sweet spot of the type of
people that you want to build
relationships with is it the hiring
managers plus the internal recruiters
plus the like what what's ended up being
this sort of recipe of like you know
what if we've got a relationship with
you know one person not a r t and one
person here what's that ended up looking
like out of Interest so yeah that's an
interesting question because I think I'm
Different to other people and there's a
difference to other recruiters because
and um yeah different to most recruiters
I would say so
um a lot of people put an emphasis on me
in the hiring managers so for me within
the Arizona craft it might be like a
marketing director for example whereas
I'd say I also focus on the MSP and HR
relationships and making sure you
develop develop those relationships
because when you say MSP just so for
people not sorry to buy and so when you
say MSP what does that mean so as well
as equivalent of like an RPO um on the
contract so they out there might
Outsource yeah you might they might
Outsource their recruitment to another
company that deals with all the yeah so
they'll just look after all the um I
suppose the administer situation for
contract hiring okay we will be in the
you know the middle person between the
business and the and the recruitment
yeah sorry to buy them but some people
might not know where that is so yeah so
you were saying about yeah MSP and HR so
yeah I think it's massively underrated
that look um the relationship you have
with the MSP because you might have a
really good relationship in the business
like again I'll give the examples of the
market director so you've got the key
you know you've got key to room but the
MSP will actually give you the key to
the house they'll they'll have all the
intelligence in terms of what's going on
in that company you know future pipeline
what the initiatives are again this
manager might have that as well from
from his area but I think there's a lot
of intelligence that could be shared
with the MSP so I I I do my utmost to
build really good relationships with MSP
making sure
um everyone who's working on these rails
are giving them you know VIP treatment
making sure we don't break any of the
rules you know in place making sure we
go back quickly on all the requests
um and I just think that's very
underrated I think a lot of recruiters
out there do Focus so much on the
manager side that they forget about the
value that you can get from HR MSP RPO
this podcast is proudly partnered with
vincere the all-in-one recruitment
agency software that over 20 000
recruiters trust daily we're also
partnered with the award-winning one-up
sales the sales and motivation platform
that enables you to maximize the
potential of your teams we love
partnering with both of these
organizations because they share our
mission in helping you get the most out
of your people and your business you can
get exclusive offers because you listen
to this podcast and get up to 10 of the
usage price forever use a link in the
show notes to get your hands on that
let's get back to the episode so that's
ended up being so it's been hiring
manager HR MSP ultimately typically has
been you need to look at who's in who's
in the supply chain if you like from you
know in the process from when you do a
deal and there's there's all these
people in the middle you know and
included in that and in that process
nothing is important that you have
relationship with everyone in that
process in order to make that deal go as
smooth as possible
so let's talk about that for a second
then because I'm sure there's things
that you've helped your team with that
you do really well how I guess where
You're vulnerable there is you're one of
many I feel like it could be yeah so you
mentioned their VIP treatment so that
could look like you respect their rules
not trying to cut Corners when you do
work on things with them you're doing
your utmost to provide quality you know
you're really trying to stand out in
that way but what what else have you
found works when it comes to Matt not
being just another recruiter on a
spreadsheet that they have that gets
roles sent to them when we make them
available like what what else are you
doing to stand out to these people
because
I remember there was yeah one of my
um best clients ended up Outsourcing it
uh to a company and my initial thought
was like yeah that's that's going
to be hard and I did I'd like to think
I'm quite good at good relationships and
yeah I felt like I did a good job but I
still felt vulnerable because like I
knew that you know everyone else was
getting them and these things so what
have you found what have you found works
when it comes to really breaking the you
know the surface the surface level
relationship to Matt is now you know
more than just another supplier what
have you found work on that front yeah
so in terms of yeah tangible things so
if I was to find out some business Intel
in the company find out someone's hiring
come you know put put in a role for
approval I would this is really strange
it can sound strange but I tell the MSP
and people recruit is going to be like
oh wait say that again say that again so
I I have like I'm quite a straight shoot
I have like an open and honest
relationship like direct with managers
or MSP whoever it is so if a man if a
marketing director comes to me and says
you know we've got this role going for
approval for a market exec for example
um I would I would I would tell him to
speak I would like that because I want
to I want to be as honest as possible
and say look I've spoken to this manager
they've got a role coming up and then
when you're I think when you're honest
you're transparent they're not they and
you've got a relationship with them they
said okay thanks for you know thanks for
letting me know and they they know I'm
pipelining CVS in the background which
is you know which is absolutely fine but
also when they get some intelligence
outside of that who are they going to go
to right so they'll come to me so they
would say oh you know if I'm looking to
learn a bit more about the company you
know in a particular way or say like
there's only anyone hearing you think I
should be reaching out to or from your
perspective which areas do you think's
going to be busy because you have to
remember my coverage is quite a few
there's a few different sort of work
streams of missions in the company so
um and they'll they'll get they'll
they'll you know if you scratch air back
here they'll scratch yours so and then
that's um
yeah so like basically try and be a
transparent and share information idea
is there that they share things with you
yeah
interesting what do we do because I
remember this happening to me what
you're also vulnerable to is you do all
that work with Jeremy and Jeremy leaves
from the MSP you're like oh like
I've been doing all this great stuff for
Jeremy
we've now got Melissa in I'm back to
Ground Zero what what are we doing there
to protect ourselves like what proactive
things are you doing to make sure that
as soon as someone new comes in because
these companies also have a trip like I
I found they do can have quite a high
attrition rates these msps I don't know
what you think but then you're back to
zero essentially so what what you do
there to really account manager make
sure you don't just have one
relationship as soon as that person
leaves they'll go to another MSP you're
about to grow on um I don't really see
that because if someone I've got a good
relationship is leaving I'll know about
it I'll have to set the notice and I'd
make sure there's a Handover I'd have a
meeting with that person and the new
person then you know this is Matt he
does x y z for all of us and we'll it'll
be a smoothie it's almost like a
Handover if I was working in their team
I mean that's what I would do I wouldn't
be if someone leaves one of your
relationships leaves and you didn't know
about it I don't I went class that it's
a relationship I mean I mean research
has shown that you need to have 16
points of contact with the same person
for you to cast that as a relationship
and that could be an email
um reply it could be a phone call a
meeting breakfast lunch whatever so I
think if you look at who you would cast
this relationship how many times have
you met them are they are they a
Advocate are they a coach
um are they just someone that will
respond to you now and again you'd like
there's different strengths of
relationships I would say
um that to be fair you just basically
said that when you do get to the point
where you get the relationship they're
transparent you share things but if
they're leaving they're going to share
that with you so then you can be
proactive with when they are leaving
this would be great if we could do this
yeah so that yeah that's interesting
I've broken clients from the exact tax
exact example that I've gone out and
joined somewhere else and we've signed
them up as a client because they've
moved so someone leaving whether it's a
manager or MSP RPO whatever it's not the
worst thing because you could end up
signing a new client if you've done a
good job done a good job okay so why
don't we
why don't we just paint a bit of a
um a picture then of
how should I frame this like this is
clearly important and the core part of
your strategy so I guess what people
would probably be Keen to know like when
we think about you know breaking the
million
I think a lot of people are asking like
you know how many clients did that come
from and these types of things yeah
because what it sounds like is look if
you do all this if this if you do this
really good work building relationships
the things you're talking about
obviously the idea is you're not doing
ones and twos you're not doing freezing
fours throughout the entire in terms of
deals and placements I'm assuming we're
talking you know fifty hundred over a
hundred yep so obviously we don't we
don't need we don't want to know who
your clients are but we what I think
would be good for people to understand
to get a bit of a picture of this is
like if we do this right and our
strategy is to get him with some big
clients get on the PSL maximize those
relationships you know be really known
when that organization as someone that
delivers and supports on a lot of our
roles so we give them the opportunity
and and these things like how like how
many clients do you think
um have cut like percentage-wise maybe
have contributed to that million Mark
has it been you know three five clients
has contributed like 80 of that have
come from eight percent of that what
does that look like in terms of that
client spread so that year that I hit a
Million last year that I had 18 so I had
a contract base and about 125 on average
yeah towards the end and that was split
across 18 clients 18 clients yeah and
then the perm used in was that with
those 18 as well
um yeah that was included with within
that so I mean I've done 213k on Perm
but they're across two clients really
yeah so yeah the other
um most of it was obviously most of it
was contracts but
um yeah I mean my average I mean our
terminology is spread but I'm sure
billions of Revenue but I think my
um spread at one point was like 25 to 30
30k and I would have around
um seven or eight in my top client so
it's actually it's actually worked out
quite a while because they're quite
Diversified portfolio in terms of the
clients but not also the clients but
also the skill sets that I've got which
probably sets me up nicely in a way for
any external marking you know marketing
factors which are gonna
um you know for project Cuts in one
client I've still got the others to fall
back on yeah my my actual
um value of each deal is not massive
it's not massive either um so I'm not
talking about
um like really really really big deals
I'm talking about I've got 135
contractors in that money spread so it's
quite different fun that's interesting
that it was over
um 18 clients and then how many would
you say of that 18 were like would you
put in a category of the types of
companies you were talking about you're
on a PSL even MSP was that was that most
of them no I wouldn't I wouldn't say
most of them maybe maybe half yeah so
that's interesting yeah so we I mean
we're on the PSL for accounts where you
know we might be like one or two hours a
month that we feel but we've only got
about a core in my team about five six
that we get regular rolls from yeah
and the reason I wanted to share that is
because I feel like the other part to
this and clearly that was a big part of
the recipe for you to break that million
is like really maximizing those
relationships so why don't we just talk
for a second you've maybe given some of
it away and already spoken about it but
I think you know we've all been there
where you work extremely hard to get
onto the PSL you know you get to that
point you're you know you're now you
know you're now part of the party you're
being sent roles you're being given
opportunities
what have you had to get really good at
to maximize those opportunities because
you know your competitor could have been
put on the PSL as well being that given
access the same relationships but then
didn't nowhere near as much as you guys
did and I think this probably happens
quite a lot where and we've had a lot of
people share on here where
a lot of people work really hard to get
to the point where they're in the room
and then it's like all right okay now
I've got a shitload of work to do to
even make the most out of this night I'm
I'm not going to get loads of things
handed to me because I'm assuming it
wasn't like right we had like you had a
party internally like right guys run a
PSL and then and then four weeks later
it's like here's 50 Rose amount yeah I
mean what do you think you've done yeah
what have you had to get really good at
in terms of maximizing those accounts
you think so I think it's what comes
down to relationships again
relationships with MSP in relation to
them with the hiring managers
um as well so you just get a really good
understanding of of what they're looking
for and I suppose that comes
um that comes over time
um it's difficult to say because I mean
I don't know what's normally like other
companies I went to the same company for
sort of 10 years I mean we've I would
say out of those
um six seven I mentioned I think we like
top Supply and adds like four of them
out of the six so let me ask you this
then like because I think when we were
preparing for this one of the things
that you said to me you've mentioned
already is
um because I I said to you what do you
think Matt's most known for right and
one of the things that you said was like
providing VIP Gold Club treatment to you
know msps rpos HR relationships right so
I guess what what might be worth sharing
is is it anything that comes to mind
when it comes to besides delivering
besides Matt is someone that we know if
we give a job to and his team they're
probably going to find us someone
besides that is there anything else
you've said share information that
that's one thing is it anything else
that you think that contributes to that
VIP Gold Club trimming that you know
these people really appreciated that
maybe other people aren't doing I don't
know is it besides delivering them
besides sharing information I think
regular regular contact is definitely
one of um so I have um
uh as an account manager I'll have
um like a regular course get scheduled
with them to go to go through like open
wrecks heads up wrecks all that sort of
stuff and that's probably why once would
that be a week over two weeks yeah I've
got some that like to do every week
someone like to do every two weeks
there's some clients like msps I speak
to you literally every day and they'll
just call me sometimes just for a chat
um but yeah but you just haven't having
I suppose it's just coming back to the
relationship piece having regular
contact and you have to build up trust
over time this doesn't really happen
overnight so when I when I've done a
million
um it was the groundwork that I probably
put in the year or two before that that
enabled me to hit a million
um that year because I mean I came into
that year already doing I think it was
like 16 17K spread a week
um so that got me off to a good start
already but that was it was the
groundwork that I've done you know the
year I think it was covid well I've only
done 200 in the year after that yeah um
which really which really helps so it's
just building up that trust because I
think I do think that msps HR have there
is a
um like they do look at agencies
sometimes like just going off and doing
their own things speaking to the
business when they're not allowed and
um yeah basically breaking the rules
whereas I I make sure not just myself
I'm HMR team that doesn't happen because
it takes ages to build up the trust but
then it's something that happens that
they can just knock it all down straight
away so and I love that so I think
people will be interested in don't need
like the full agenda but like what are
like the core things that you always go
over typically like what is it that they
find helpful what is it they typically
want to you know understand and find out
is it the number of people that you guys
have reached out to that week is it the
number of CVS that you've sent over what
are the typical things that you're going
over in those meetings that they really
appreciate yep so I think um always
communicating the challenges you're
having on the difficult roles so if
there's like sourcing challenges making
sure you're letting them know like
before the deadline so if it's like
typically the roles we'll have in
contracts will be
um 40 hour deadline
um if we're looking like we're really
struggling um it might be a niche skill
set we'll let the we'll let the MSP know
just so you know this is what we're
struggling on
um so just that communication piece
again
um sharing and sharing intelligence
which was obviously already already
mentioned and I think a lot of the time
it's just if you if you're good at
sending if you're if you've got a good
if you've got a good source a good
delivery team that's sending good
candidates that's almost half the battle
because that's what the end of the day
they want to hit the slas that's what
they want it's quickly as possible so if
you're sending good candidates you'll
filling the roles quickly then that's
the most important thing yeah
so why don't we appreciate you sharing
that so why don't we talk about what
what does this day of yours look like
then because I think that's what a lot
of people will be curious about we've
spoken about I think you've you've
you've shared with us what strategies
work for you getting in with these big
accounts and maximizing them we've
spoken a lot about relationships these
types of things
but I think a lot of people were really
curious around particularly with your
dual desking like how does Matt set up
his day like what does that look like
and you've said well you've got really
good at is making sure that you're you
know spending time on the things that
hopefully are going to equate to you
know the outcomes that you're hoping for
rather than spending loads of time on
things that maybe aren't high value so
let's talk about this eight to six then
that you typically try and yeah that you
typically uh have experienced like what
because obviously you manage a team as
well yep so talk to us a bit about how
you structure your day like what does
that look like so we have a at 8 30 like
a like a team meeting to go over all the
open wrecks that happens every day like
Candace that we're interviewing any
deals that we're looking to close
um I run like a a sales meeting straight
after that as well with the sales guys
looking to see what meetings they've got
booked in what they had just what being
said yesterday what outcomes are there
meetings they have yesterday going
through their like manager spreadsheet
and looking who they're targeting so
it's quite a detailed one every every
day outside of like those particular
meetings is different
um like I usually
um plan for the day like the next day
the day before in the evening because
anything can happen sort of during you
know during that day
um yeah so it's it's it's yeah very and
five o'clock like an agile an agile
process yeah like it can change whenever
but
um what a lot of the sort of normal
thing the normal non-negotiable so
you've got setting the team up sales
team overall like Rex we've got open but
then typically what would end up taking
a bulk of your time or what do you
typically find yourself doing most of
the time because that's going to be the
things that are probably going to be the
highest leverage activities that you're
going to be doing yeah so I'm putting my
sales hat on
um an hour and a half will be spent on
prospecting every day so looking at the
looking at the account I'm going to be
targeting then I would spend an hour on
execution so that would be
personalized Outreach whether it be
calls or or emails I might have a couple
of meetings already scheduled in that
day I might have some account management
stuff to do as well in that day
one-to-ones Etc
how do you how have you helped your team
because I know this is something a lot
of managers and recruiters struggle with
how because like a common sentence I
think right now as well a lot of
recruitment leaders can sort of easily
hear their team go oh I haven't ended up
doing that BD or I haven't ended up
doing this
like how have you helped your team
understand
what are the true priorities and what
they should be given more time to rather
than all these other things that make
you feel good that you've got it done
because that can be difficult for a lot
of people yeah and people get
sidetracked right but I think you as a
as a non-negotiable for a salesperson
that is their that is their job right it
is to do BD so if that I'd be interested
they'll sit them down say okay what
what's getting in your way of doing this
you know what what you know what is side
tracking you away from doing your job
and I'd actually sit yeah sit down with
them and go through that because it's
like comes back to to uh like kpis which
are you know which are put in place
they're non-negotiable they're based on
you know if you hit these you should hit
Target but you know that's why these are
in place so it'll just come you know
come back to that and then as a manager
curious like what what are the
dashboards that you're always keep an
eye on what are they like the key
metrics that you always keep an eye on
that makes you feel like you've got a
good sense of you being on track or not
on track to to hit the the targets that
you've set yep so for sales it would be
uh meetings and Rex picked up and over
the maybe over the course of a longer
period it'll be clients broken you know
accounts broken uh for talent it'll be
um people spoken to kind of spoken to
um submittals interviews candida
meetings yeah
not that curious with the sales people
um for sales people
obviously it's all that it's like all
Downstream from from having that client
meeting what have you what are you
finding at the moment be the most
effective way for your team to get that
first client meeting because that's
often the most difficult to get in
um making sure the right Outreach is
really personalized so I'm not a big oh
well I'm saying not a big fan that's
probably an understatement I hate cold
calling I don't agree with it I think
it's waste of time it's coming back to
working smart and I don't think cold
calling is working smart unless you see
your time
um I would suggest to my I suggest my
sales team that they reach out to at
least 20 new managers a day whether it
be an email personalized email
Oracle but each even that would be to
one client but each of those emails
would be personalized and different well
yeah we try and Target one at One A Day
right so one say try and Target one
client a day but 20 different people in
there yeah 20 different people in there
but each of those will be different
because they're HP personalized and then
like different parts of the business
yeah yeah it's I suppose it's um it
might be different for myself because
you know we look after different um
areas but yeah that's what we were
talking about
personalized I feel like is quite an
overused word these days yeah so like
for me for me when I because I agree
with you on the personalized piece
would definitely are would definitely
argue for me with the with the cooling
piece
it's more about like being smart with
what you can do before you make that
call but the call the call is is
effective but like it's like what hasn't
that done before you know he's called me
that could potentially give me a better
chance of being given that moment to
explain why I've called specifically
them
so yeah I do think is it a good use of
time to just call you and I haven't
really spent any time thinking about why
I'm calling you and I haven't really
thought about my value proposition and
these things but if you have got an
email you know if you emailed me and
said hey look over you know that you
know the other guys in such and such
Department we've delivered uh this
hiring project for them mentioned that
you're struggling with a few things do
you think you'd you know would you be
against having a chat yep I didn't reply
to you but then you called me and then
you know you used that to try and you
know be part of the conversation I think
that's just a smart way of using the
phone but I actually do think now if
you're willing to pick up the phone it
actually gives you a competitive
Advantage because so many people
together doing that do you think so yeah
100 right okay I mean I don't see that I
mean I'd worry if there's a salesperson
yeah and that's a job to call managers
if they're scared of picking up the
phone
um that would be a worry for me yeah but
it's like let's break down like because
you've said you don't you're like you're
it's an understatement to say that you
don't like phone calls right yeah
an intro call to a manager could be
fairly similar really to a personalized
email right so when I say I don't I
don't like cold calls I don't like blank
it's the same thing for some reason I
don't like blanket emails going out to
you know every you know head off or
director in an industry I don't think
it's a good good way when you say
personalized because clearly you're
passionate about that well what does
that mean for you personally so a
personalized Trigger or like the first
line an email could be anything from
like you just said you could have been
introduced by someone else you could
name drop someone in the company it
could be
um some something that that manager
posted on LinkedIn
um you know shared could have posted a
role six months ago
um it could even be something about his
area that you found out you know a bit
of intelligence you found out from a
candidate or in the research you've
you've done so
um yeah it's quite it could be it could
be anything as long as it's personalized
to that person and then
um then you would bring in I suppose the
business challenge is like what you just
said they understand you know you might
be struggling with these highs or it
could be uh more of a just a general
challenge in the market and you'd
hopefully have some sort of solution
where you delivered that for either a
competitor or someone else within that
company and then you'll get in your your
team to then follow up with phone calls
and stuff like that you don't think
that's a waste of time you're thinking
you're saying if I have a list of
companies have done any research on them
at all and I'm just calling for a list
how useful is that how good I suppose
when I think of cold call I'm that's
what I'm talking about yeah I'm talking
about sending the same inmate or emails
every single one it's not targeted yeah
yeah curious getting a bit grander here
uh what do you think because I'm sure
you helped your team with this what do
you think a good club meeting looks like
okay so I think you need to have a
really specific agenda on what you're
looking to get out and you can maybe
have two to three objectives you're
looking to get off that meeting
typically these meetings will last what
half an hour maybe an hour if you're
lucky and then that agenda again this
should be different for every meeting
you have but that agenda should be based
around the outcomes that you're you're
looking you're looking for so
right okay
um I don't know you might you you the
the outcome could be you might know this
person's got a role for example so the
outcome could be you're looking to
um you know looking to pick up a role it
could without commute you might be
looking to map out his team so how has
his team set up is it contract perm does
he have any Consultants or whatever
um so I would make sure my agenda was
based around based around that and I had
those questions lined up for that for
that meeting nice
um he didn't your team doing the look
that means a video These Days although
you're trying to push more face to face
yeah a lot of the yeah to be family
we're based in London I mean a lot of
the um a lot of the clients we work with
outside of London or we do UK UK and
Ireland but when we can do we do mainly
sort of lunches and breakfast but not
too many coffee meets anymore it's my
new breakfast lunches yeah curious just
because like this is obviously been a
core part of your strategy now I'm going
to hit you with some questions that
people uh shared uh
how
a very common objection that recruiters
say that they find hard to deal with is
the PSL one
so I'm just curious to like hear your
thoughts on navigating that objection
because
I feel like almost you're like well
that's great most of our clients we work
on a PSL and we're one of their top
providers so like when you know when I'm
your Target customer and you speak to me
and I say look I'm sorry we've got a PSL
in place yeah like what are the typical
things that you help you you know your
team uh with and like how do you
typically never get that because
yeah like that's that's your world it
seems yeah well as an objection I would
I would ask open questions just to find
out how is he finding that process you
know what is the PSL doing for you yeah
because there will be a challenge in
there somewhere um and so like how would
the PSL performing
um what would you say they're good at
what would you say they're not good at
and try and get that business challenge
out of him that pain point in order to
then provide provide that solution
what's the most common one that you
typically uncover
um
is quite a common one
um uh yeah the wrong top CVS or maybe
speed to delivery it's probably another
one especially especially in contracts
um they're probably the biggest two I
would say and I think those two things
are something that we're quite well
equipped and quite set up well on
and if again curious because you're not
going to be able to go from that that
phone call to but okay Matt sounds great
let me sign you into the PSL it doesn't
quite work like that yeah so I'm just
curious because these types of companies
that you're targeting
is if I say to you you know what Matt
that sounds great and that's you know
what we want to be able to say our PSL
is doing but they're not but we don't
renew until six months or yeah these
things what is typically the thing in
between maybe the moments where you can
generally have an opportunity to be
considered and get onto PSL what what
are you trying to make sure happens in
the meantime are you trying to get
meetings in with them to at least
educate them on how you've had other
companies like theirs get to know them
are you trying to just be you know given
that at least a sliver of an opportunity
to say look if they do continue to
struggle please get an opportunity and
we can sort of show what we can do like
what are the typical things that you try
and lean on in between the moments where
you just literally can't get on the the
PSL because you'll that'll be the case
right yeah I mean we get that quite a
lot as well with light PSL reviews I
mean you know sometimes there's not much
you can do if they if that is if that is
genuine but we would um you know one of
the things you just said we'd ask for an
option just give us a difficult
opportunity that's not been filled and
we'll show you guys what we can do with
that um we would also share um because
we have regularly what we call
business reviews with
um with our msps and HR and they'll
provide us actual statistics on you know
the deals that we're doing how quickly
we deliver and it's got all it's
everything there and we would you know
with with their permission we would
share that information with respective
clients um
um and so so they can they can show us
or we can even say look you will give
you the details go and speak to them
find out how good we are um to make sure
we're when it does come to the review
um we're in a good spot
yeah I love that so many recruiters
don't do enough of that because there's
what I can sit here and feel your
passion and have you say like
with the things you can do for me but
then there's a whole other thing a whole
nother like it's a no it will feel
completely different if I've got another
MSP saying this is what they did and
here are the sort of case studies of
what they've done for us over the last
six 12 months yeah
see if you're listening to this and you
haven't got any case studies wrapped up
and you're not using them like you you
seriously are missing a trick
yeah I think that's yes I'm not
surprised you said that that's a great
way again and you've got more chance of
having these types of things I guess
potentially because like you said these
msps have to sit hit their slas that's
what they really care about so this is
all going to be measured on their end
let alone not just your end yeah exactly
yeah do you know what I mean so to be
able to Showcase that so let me hear you
some quick five questions then because I
want to make sure I've uh covered the
things that people have asked don't
worry I'm not gonna I'm gonna ask you
some of the the Rogue ones
um so I think we've gone through a lot
of the ones where people wanted to know
you know breakdown or perm contract
um
I quite like this one like why if I was
to say to you why do clients work with
you and your team what how would you
answer that I think a few people are
curious in that I'm like why do you
think they give you the work why do you
think clients work with you guys over
others
um
some of the stuff I've already mentioned
in terms of like just being good at what
we do and making sure we're delivering
delivering on the roles we say we're
going to deliver on not over you know
over promising and under under
delivering uh making sure we have the
regular contacts when this is this is
the feedback that we that we receive
when we when we do our you know annual
uh feedback to clients that's the sort
of stuff we we receive in terms of just
doing what we we say we're gonna do this
will be an interesting one so you've
spoken to us about the breakdown of the
clients repeat business are you are you
doing any sort of productization of your
service like or is it just you know like
with the you know the contractor spread
that you spoke about and then are you
sort of saying well look why didn't you
work with us to you know
um deal with uh helping you find these
15 contractors or you're always talking
about the individual like you know I
mean have you done anything like that
yeah we have done
um exclusive business on contract as
well like outside of the what we say the
usual methods or usual program and that
that's obviously what we're class is
very like you know good good business
I've got
um I can repeat projects that I don't
you know that probably brings me about
10 deals a quarter that I get from
um which is which is good I mean um
because most of it contingent then is
that fair yeah yeah yeah yeah especially
contingent I mean yeah from a contract
perspective but I mean on average last
year I was doing probably about 25 to 35
deals a quarter so probably about two
three a week my biggest call was I think
Q3 I've done that 45 deals nothing maybe
10 of those are on exclusive so okay
so I think you spoke a lot of people
interested in you know what's been the
most effective way for you to win
business I'm right and saying I feel
like from today it's about really
doubling down that personalized approach
really did an upfront work of
understanding who you're contacting
understanding as much you can about
their business mapping out the people in
the stakeholders in the organization and
then being really smart with you know
how you're reaching out to them and then
just being consistent you know one you
know one company a day 20 people that's
what it seemed like you you shared today
yeah yeah exactly I mean um just coming
back to that strategic BD versus all
transactional like when you're
prospecting your clients you the last
thing you want to do is like book one
meeting in 30 different clients in a
quarter you know that you're not going
to break clients from doing that so make
sure you're smart with the time that
you're yeah that you're using and going
off to a Better Business and I think a
lot of people would be curious about
this and then
um I'll have one more question but
I think how how is it set up in terms of
like your your like team then because a
lot of people be like okay yeah Matt's
done a million but how many how many
split deals he's doing how many you know
how many people has he got support in
them because you obviously you've spoken
about the structured team you've got
sales team how obviously we don't need
to know the percentage of like what you
know delivery people get to you I'm not
bothered about that but like what does
it actually look like have you got you
know you're bringing the clients you're
spending time with it on the account
management side are you doing any of the
candidate fulfillment do you have you
know one or two people specifically just
work with you like what does that
typically look like yeah so we used to
be a 360 model and we moved to 180 and
I'd say just for my experience I think
that's the right thing to do if you want
to grow your business quickly and
aggressively
um I've always been a I suppose an
advocate of having the you know the the
best people if you're really good at
sales you should be focused on that and
not worry about sourcing and if you're
really good on the candidate and
performance side you should be
specializing and become a master in that
and not worrying about anything else
um since we moved to that model is I
really recently it's like halfway
through towards the end of last year
um we're still in the transition phase
but we can see the potential benefits
from that now in our team we've got
um so we've got 13 so we've got one
talent talent lead and we've got
um eight recruiters so eight Talent
Associates which do the sources we've
got like two thousand Associates per
sales per sales person right yeah and
they're more specialists in say actual
procurement sales marketing and customer
service and admin right so you
potentially have like two yeah two
personals person
um on that side yeah that's how we say
so basically you're you're producing
that with a team of ultimately like
there's three of you ultimately it seems
what do you mean so you you creating you
know you doing a million
that's you and then two other people
supporting you achieve that right yeah
in terms of what you would say split
deals is not necessarily the same two
people though because yeah but like in
terms of like that isn't just a little
bit how has Matt done that on his own do
you have done that you know that's been
a TF right but obviously a huge factor
of even getting to that point is having
the opportunity and having the companies
to do that with but the way you set it
up is you've always got
two people or people that you can lean
on to help you fulfill those those jobs
basically look after the look after the
sourcing yeah so it's quite rare I mean
sometimes now and again I'll have to get
involved in sourcing uh to try and
support on the more difficult roles but
yeah that yeah their job is to find you
it's my job to go and pick up the roles
it's their job to to find the candidates
all right well let's just end with this
then like decades a long time a lot of
people you know listen to this podcast
would love to get to the opportunity to
you know break a million achieve their
goals or get into this industry to
achieve big things so what what would
you you know be your partnering advice
for anyone that wants to you know aspire
to be
you know as successful as they hope when
they join the industry like what would
you say is the the sort of one thing
that maybe you continue to find yourself
giving the advice to the people around
you and your team what would you want to
leave people with so I would say um uh
yeah to just make sure
um it comes out to like I suppose comes
out to accountability I'd say I'd say
when you make mistakes make sure you
learn from them and if something
happened if something happens like I
don't know you've got to drop out on a
candidate for example
um don't blame everyone else for it
don't blame the candidate um don't blame
the client don't blame the recruitment
Gods looking down on you like what could
you have done differently in that
situation so if you've had a drop out
why is it drop out you know did you
qualify that candidate properly and if
you have if you go into that everything
that you do in recruitment with the
right mindset in terms of learning from
your mistakes and not not
um blaming everyone else all the time
which I which unfortunately is like a
natural reaction sometimes to when
something goes wrong
um I think you would always learn and
develop and I'm still doing that now
when I'm in mistakes now it's like okay
what shall I've done differently did I
handle that correctly
and I'd say that's probably one of the
important most important things I would
say that's been a pleasure thank you so
much cheers mate
thank you so much for listening to the
episode I hope you enjoyed it and got
value from the conversation if you did
enjoy it please don't forget to like
share and subscribe and we'll see you in
the next episode